[Music]
all right Saget we did career that was
it that was my career is just beginning
literally our career ended my career
completely it ended
we never got best fuller house / no we
did Benjamin we're good we did Benjamin
we you know we got weird all this stuff
coming yeah we didn't even talk about
half-baked
but we'll just know that we'll just say
that it never actually did that in real
life my love never did the real life you
know got it okay all right let's talk I
just want to about politician just kind
of what you think is going on in the
world because that's what you do here
that is what I do here but even though I
only know you a little bit from the
conversation we had at dinner I got just
got a sense that like you actually
you're obviously very sensitive like
that's pretty clear I'm overly sensitive
little like you want people to be
treated well and fair ever think of
myself as a liberal must be well what
did I think I look at myself as a
humanist I was on a plane the other day
which no comedians ever said and the
gentleman was on the plane and he had
and he was about 60 years old and he
seemed like a successful businessman of
some kind and I was in the first class
section because there was a cat back in
coach it was a cat for a case you get
sick she had her security animal to keep
her what do you call those animal the
you know special animal yeah the may use
special needs
yeah animo or whatever but I'm a deathly
allergic so I was up front I know cats
do same thing so I was saying to this
gentleman and he had on big bright red
america-first
shirt and so if I was a I guess a what
you brand as a liberal I guess that
shirt would bother me but I just looked
at the guy and he seemed like a nice guy
I didn't I just said do you have an
allergy to cats he went no my wife's got
a cat I said so you have a cat ago no my
wife has a cat and when we laughed a
little bit and
what it said on a shirt on his shirt
isn't a shirt I would wear it's not
where I'm at I mean I do believe I do
believe I love America I believe that
where you live you want to put first you
want to take care of your people you
want to take care of your hometown oh
you're coming out with that far-right
craziness or you want to take care of
your country oh but down the narrow
narrow down down down down down but I
don't but I'm not if you're if you're
kind and you're not out doing some
closet hatred or blatant hatred I don't
know but I just look at my dad's whole
thing was be kind to people so it sounds
like a pacifist might bother people but
that's what we're supposed to do yeah is
the problem with that that you just get
nipped off by both sides I mean I see
that a lot now that I do think there's
this interesting Center developing I
don't even know other's sides I mean I
of course not yeah of course I do
yeah but you know and the and people go
well you're a Democrat right now I'm
like I'll vote for anybody that can get
us out of this mess
you know I bring my dad back from the
grave and vote for him he'd be such a
good candidate a living a Grateful Dead
video yeah I don't know
try agree where are you when you
consider yourself a liberal is that
where you are yeah I still consider
myself a liberal but most of the liberal
things that I believe in I can pretty
much explain from a libertarian
perspective right and that I just don't
want the government involved in my life
that's it and I think you should live
your life however you see fit and I'll
live mine however I see fit like you
have a lot more money than me right fair
to say I don't know but we're gonna do
spreadsheet exams right after this is
over let's be clear I'm on YouTube
you've been on network television you've
got three chickens outside I don't have
three chickens I don't know their value
but you could have chickens the point is
I don't deserve any of your stuff just
because you make more money than me
right I can't have any of your money it
would be nice I suppose but I don't
deserve any but that's what taxes are
about and that's where our incredibly
rich society and our incredibly
poor society are at odds with each other
and that has been since the beginning of
time since you know castles were built
with a dictator and a king living in it
yeah and everybody had to go build all
this stuff and they were slaves so I
mean it's it does it the metaphor
doesn't change the representation
doesn't change that the downtrodden are
downtrodden and are disgruntled and then
other people are angry at things that
that they should just take a freaking
chill pill over yeah
well that cuts an outrage thing well
there's a lot to be outraged over also
because all the the problem with you
know wanting to entertain people was
wanting to be a comedian is it's nearly
impossible when there's so many deaths
when there's so many tragic things
happening which there always have been
but we are at a news ratio where it's
coming at us you just you know you hit
your computer on and it says you know
news alert and you hit news alert and
you're like you're afraid to hit the
button you're afraid to get up at the
Morton and hit whatever news service you
yeah go to so that's just a matter of us
knowing about it more because I have
Steven Pinker on next week who's a
Harvard psychologist who and his whole
argument is actually that things are
better than they've ever been abusing
empirical scientific evidence about the
amount of people that are being exposed
quicker well because we actually have
more people out of poverty now worldwide
than ever before more people with
drinkable water than ever before more
people that live in mobile environment
Enlightenment values and everywhere but
we see more people with drinkable water
yeah more than not around the world no
way around the world more now than ever
before
well that might be true is that our we
hundred percent that's true I'm pretty
sure that's true but what about what
about more people being murdered what
about the safety of our kids what about
you know all these things over but
Gonzo's most of those markers actually
they're better than ever before
it's just that we hear about them all
the time now right and we obsess over
them not and we and we obsess over the
negative yeah because we're now
presented the positive and if we're
presented the positive it's through a
skewed broadcast it's it's it's not
really presented by someone that
comforts you this show comforts you more
than most shows because of the way you
handle it
that's just a fact this is you're trying
to watch use several times you're trying
to put two factions together that might
have similar or opposed views discussing
opposed views and are saying why can't
it be like this because if you try to go
toward an idealistic goal the dream of
it is how you can almost get there
that's that's how the country was
founded besides you know taking a lot of
things away from the people that lived
here that's a whole other show that
you've got three [ __ ] in your yard
pretty good so I just try to get you out
of this now yeah I'm not really
politically astute but did I make any
sense yeah well you are making some
sense but I think you actually are I
mean you're around Mara all the time
well that must be I saw just last night
and he said Aloha cuz we were in Hawaii
together yeah but I do say that I'd
rather get my news from you know from
John Oliver and and Bill Maher and
Stephen Colbert and Seth Meyers and
Jimmy Kimmel then the newscasters what
does that tell you about just media we
we need a relief and so the news itself
is already a parody and it's also so
obsessive no matter where it's coming
from and we're also dealing with a
regime which flip-flops in the media and
on Twitter faster than I then its ever
existed because we never had a president
tweet us you know this just did we did I
mean Obama did but right but it wasn't
it was it like I hate this I love this
you know
18:21 you know 21:18 it's like you're in
Vegas yeah you know just double down do
you see him as the problem though or is
a symptom because I
really see well I think that the symptom
he is a symptom it was it was voting for
a guy that was on a show that said
you're fired so what do you expect to
get you know if you're gonna if you're
gonna get the host of America's Got
Talent
you're gonna get the most out of people
it's good to be the the best procession
ever it could be dancers and singers and
yeah if you had been the president
people would be getting big jokes no you
you would from me I guarantee you a dick
joke a day and I would tweet them and
not three in the morning I do not tweet
well three in the morning no one should
know well no one except the president
because but but I just think you know
what did we expect but I think a lot of
people were surprised and I think it
doesn't matter it's happening yeah and
this is it and so we want a better
humanity and there are great people in
the world and there are great people in
other countries leading the world the
best they can and there's a lot of
slackers and there's other people that
are just part of the political bunch of
crap but they're still great people and
there's great people watching this
there's nice people watching your show
yeah you're a nice person nice people
you don't I don't think you get a lot of
haters do you get I having a ridiculous
amount of haters you do yeah because I
talk about the problems that I see with
the modern-day left and the Liberals and
they don't like someone to address those
things that was once one of them but I
got this great fake manner why can't
they they don't fall don't fall for that
well I'm like a perfect shrink come on
could you could calm me down through
tightrope walking that was because we
slipped a little thing in your water
there is something in my water I'm
feeling different yes notice the tone is
change I'm not leaving I'm on the show
tomorrow are the walls vibrating it oh
yeah oh I bet he's moved in yeah there
anyone that is an eye chart behind you
you know that it says Los Angeles but
it's an eye chart
pretty clever huh yeah that's really it
we call that art [ __ ] well done Mr
Bond pretty good is there anyone that
you're paying attention to these days
that you
he's making some sense because I
appreciate all the comments but the
compliments but like that's what I think
I'm doing here is just trying to make a
little sense of something to me to be
honest John Oliver has been I can't
think of anyone political that has made
me go well there is a great hope there
and I'm interested in something some
people had to say that seemed wow that
was noble but they're not gonna do
anything about it or they're not gonna
run or but I'd like to think there's
someone out there you know I'd like to
think you think that's part of it that
we all talk a lot but we don't do I
sense that's sort of what's happening
here yeah so is that everyone's saying
[ __ ] that's all it is
we're fighting always just a bunch of
[ __ ] voices it's frequencies
everywhere gone all through our heads
it's just noise so Trump was like
alright I'm gonna do it none of you do
anything and Trump's like alright I'll
do it I'll run for president you morons
and guess what he was right yeah and the
way he does it he can turn anything he
wants into a rally if he feels the
moment and he gets the right South Park
background behind yeah but he's doing it
and I don't know I just don't know
anything it's too you can't predict a
thing and we want that security is
feeling secure that you know at least
what tomorrow brings we don't know what
an hour from now brings we have never
been on our haunches more not knowing
what's gonna come out of him out of the
White House who's going to get fired but
that's not the issue the issue is
where's the world at and where's our
kids at and where are the things that
really matter what really matters is
people this is sort of like you're
giving me the ending of a full house
episode and you know I want to tell you
something else see honey I don't want
you drinking beer at the prom and you
cannot have a horse in the living room
this is where the synthesizer music yeah
yeah and you know what always follow
your gut because your guts not wrong if
you feel it deep inside then take
imodium because any moment there could
be a release
I wish I could have done full house like
that that would have been nice totally
didn't give you a chance for bloopers
like that where you could just Oh their
bloopers yeah grills that were that I
said horrific things yeah
theirs is I wrote a book called dirty
daddy and i stoled I talked about
something I did on the set once and I
got in a lot of trouble I won't say what
it is because it's it's not repeatable
on this YouTube channel but it is in
that book and it was something I should
not have done with with a well I can't I
can't say it but it was something that
happened because big something okay I
did something that we had stand-ins for
the kids that were mannequins and I was
alone on the set with just the crew and
the monitors were on and I didn't know
that not acceptable under these
conditions no we're under this time do
you ever worry about that because you
you still I mean no because everything
someone goes oh someone's gonna come for
wind when's you're being bad thing gonna
come out I don't know look at my last
special yeah you want it it's right
there in a weird way that's like you're
it's like your saving grace sort of like
you know I am a confessional yeah I mean
and there's a story in there in 0 to 60
this special where I say I was given
ludes by a club owner which were serious
drugs it was a yes like a roofie
terrible drug from wolf of wallstreet
Jonah Hill and and Leo DiCaprio and a
club owner told me to give it to a
waitress and I could have my way with
her and I instead to cut to the chase
and ruin a joke I actually took it
myself to knock myself out so because
she was kind of hitting on me because I
did it too that's kind of guy am so all
my stuff's out there because I didn't I
didn't do anything
diabolical that I can recall seeing
yourself right can you yes yeah can you
can you add that I can recall to every
single thing I said on this entire
interview that's what politicians do
okay so I'm gonna come in and I'm gonna
voice-over this new hire interview
so that I can recall yeah I feel we
should end this either with something
hitting you in the nuts or Sun or a song
or else we could do a song but you
already gave me the nice full house
ending what do you think is you you are
the one here with the brain tell me what
you think is the hope of know how this
how we connect it is communication yeah
that this is happening now that people
are doing this that you know what I mean
your divorce your fiance Kelly came
across me we traded a couple messages on
Twitter I was like oh she gets it like
she's trying to find some answers I'm
trying to find some answers and she we
went out for dinner we all became
friends immediately yeah and that people
and that whatever differences that we
may have we're you know you're probably
still a little more left than I am on
something or what just doesn't even
matter
yeah mine I think on some things
probably you're probably a little more
yeah I know it doesn't erode I dress
left
I don't know that counts it just doesn't
even matter but the point is that that
the reason that shows like this are
working is because of this that you were
willing to come here sit down
I wanted to come here yeah yeah you
immediately said to me that you wanted
to come but at that point it's like
people want this now they are so tired
of the other thing and all we're doing
is exactly what Tom Snyder did and he
was just talking to the camera but or
what Carl he had a guess or what William
F Buckley or any of these people who
said let's try to find some answers and
you can get I think as many answers from
Bob Saget as you can from the guys I get
I think you get far more answers from
listening to someone like you who has
some life experience and that cares then
you can virtually listening to CNN all
day long well you can get what we never
got into which we don't I don't want to
get into which is all the death that I
have in my family so much death of
friends I just lost someone today they
just I think man we can go there I'm bad
luck well all I was gonna say was that's
what centers everybody because the
things we all go through our birth and
death and they all happen differently
and when they happen at an unfortunate
age like I lost two sisters at 34 and 47
that's that's what centers you that
bigger than everything is the loss of
life and when people die when young
people die there's nothing more that's
all that matters
yeah the rest of it is your belief this
is that this is that it's yes you want
to solve in a civilization how to keep
people alive but the empathy is what's
missing and just quickly to touch on
what we didn't touch him but we talked
about before the show started you know
okay
I like the talk shows that exist at
night the chat shows as they call them
in England when I would do Johnny Carson
show and before him was Jack Parr who I
got to meet and before him was Steve
Allen who I got to meet and these are
guys that they all had The Tonight Show
those gentlemen
and then Johnny ended up with it that
was viewed how they would tell their
guests you're coming to a cocktail party
mm-hmm how do I dress like a cocktail
party how do I talk you're at a cocktail
party you're in Johnny's living room and
he's sharing that living room with
everybody well why does he have a desk
in his living because he wants a desk he
wants a place for his ashtray he smokes
got a little maybe he's got a drink
there whatever that's why I believe even
that that they used to do that I mean I
there's a lot I can like what they're
smoking they're drinking you know Burt
Reynolds is wasted I mean it's amazing
and that's not what we want we don't
want to see it although sometimes we do
we see some strange things that happened
I mean Letterman certainly had some you
know Joaquin Phoenix moments those kind
of things we're still gonna see more
stuff like that people are gonna do
whatever trippy stuff they're doing but
the truth of it is those late-night
shows are supposed to be entertainment
that's what they're supposed to be
they've become a bit of let's attack
everything today yeah that we've been
through because look what happened today
because it's been getting ratings and
people that necessarily might not do
political comedy like James Corden he's
an entertainment oriented man he's been
very childhood man from Broadway he does
care at carpool karaoke he but he comes
on to some minute monologue that might
have a bunch of
stuffing it about the White House but
that's not he's not born and do that but
that's what's feeding the beast yeah but
it's supposed to be a time where you
chill at the end of the day where you're
entertained where you relax and when you
want to get that Tom Schneider when you
want to get that dare I say the name in
a sentence Charlie Rose cuz that's what
he did he did a one-on-one but when you
say a name like that it can't help but
cause someone to recoil because say
Larry King for my purposes Larry King
I've known forever and I adore ya he's a
great guy Larry King posed to have
dinner with him Kelly and I are supposed
to go ahead with him and Seana out for
dinner we can go to that place if you
invest on that place that we went that
place a we would that we don't talk
about yeah what does like that place he
is quite a character
he I went on Lion King show he read my
book every time he sees me he goes I
loved your book Saget and I don't think
it's because he he forgot that he keeps
telling me but he's just I've just known
him a long time yeah and and he he was
very very good at it you know and we've
got we have some really good people
doing the news there's some real good
people out there
I mean lawrence O'Donnell is a friend of
mine III like him a lot that name right
there might flag people yeah it will
MSNBC yeah and too many consonants we
hate it but I I don't know I just see we
need to be entertained it's really
complicated to do it at this time in a
way without bringing up human issues
moral issues and I'm gonna do the best I
can to do that you know it's funny I
remember so I was never even though I
think you know him personally I was
never a fan of Leno on The Tonight Show
I loved Carson even though it was my
kind of very early years but Leno to me
I always liked the Bill Hicks thing more
and you know they had that rival and I
like that sort of more raw morality and
Leno to me was like he was just the
corporate version so I never liked it
but in an odd way I suddenly had this
bizarre respect for him now well it was
he was a comedian hosting the Tonight
Show yeah and I mean that he wasn't
overtly political all the time now it's
always political and I almost missed
that in a way even though he wasn't
really my guy
in terms of comedy but I know I know
everyone says he's an incredible
stand-up which I use it has nothing to
do with is a great standup I was an
intern on the Mike Douglas show Wow with
in Philadelphia at 18 years old and I
was on his very first television
appearance Wow so I know Jay that long
and so there's a interesting history and
then you know Johnny Carson David
Letterman Conan those were guys that I
would go on those shows and I felt the
most connection but Jay I would go on
and promote a movie I had worked on that
I directed that I worked so hard and he
couldn't have been more gracious you
know so yeah I don't you have to be
Kimmel is one of the sweetest people
alive that does this you know and
Colbert's great I mean it's an
interesting time for media and for
broadcasting I just want to see us get
into some kind of place of peace a mind
in the world and we're not there that's
a big lift man I mean that's right like
that's why I'm doing this that's why you
want to I think do this I've never
wanted to do so I I've never wanted to
perform more I'm more motivated to go to
stand-up I booked these 10 I'm on tour
I'm trying to work out trying to come up
with new stuff because I you know you do
a special and you deplete it but you you
know you don't want to just give them
something they just bought or heard but
people really need it and I need to do
it because it takes people out of it
brings them into their life you know the
comics are like the last cents makers
these days there's a couple others that
I think there's a few there's a few
comedians that I would rather watch than
almost anybody there are some good
motivational speakers there's some good
good clergy out there I'm not a
subscriber
that much well I'm a comedian so I kind
of listened to the people that have a
lot to say and some of them really do
have a lot to say so I respect I respect
people with a point of view that aren't
malicious now be you
did we do it all here I think pretty
much unless you want you got a walk you
want to make some vegetables I do have a
great walk and I knew you had a walk
only one disaster story one like just
nightmare I was telling you before about
my my thing when I was on at the RNC
convention and I was sweating like crazy
and Larry King said it's much more like
like Albert Brooks in broadcast news I
was on stage after them to take us out
with a disaster a disaster of stand-up
but anything give me some life very well
think it's give me a professional not a
life disaster might give you a life
disaster you how about one life name
their name dropping like disaster yeah
I'm on an airplane on America on a 747
I'm on the video show which is number
one at the time so you can then list
famous people on the plane in the
newspaper by who's the most famous no
they're listed in the newspaper but I
was on a plane with David Bowie and am
on and Greg Kinnear and Richard Lewis
had this was an American flight out of
JFK to LA that's Larry and also mark
McEwan who was on the CBS Morning News
and a friend of mine and so the plane
starts taking off this would never exist
today as we're taking off in the air we
hear an explosion and one of the engines
apparently blows out the plane goes
rickety we then land at JFK this is a
very long time ago and we find out first
they take the VIPs which is people I
named on two carts and Richard Lewis is
yelling with next to David Bowie only a
couple of us are Jews I'm like that's
not not to this so now we're in the club
and I'm getting to talk to David Bowie
so I'm going okay this was worth an
explosion on and who could not have been
more gracious and and it was just a it
was dangerous and upsetting they two
hours go by they put us back on the same
plane turns out it was a fuel hose that
came loose which is just like turning a
screw on a gasket on your lawnmower
and they fixed it which would never
happen now they would get you a new
plane or cancel you completely or
whatever right and we then took off and
I made some joke I think the movie
outbreak had just come out and I said
something like there was a monkey caught
in the in the engine and then Richard
Lewis yells out that's a good one Bob
Amon is from Zaire and so I'm called out
and then as we take off Richard Lewis
yells thanks Bob
to the whole plane and at that time you
can go into the cockpit just probably
left but you know you know yeah of 911
and I was able to ask the pilots what
happened so I actually told the VIPs no
one else yeah what happened but they
didn't tell the other people so that was
a that's true disaster story I mean that
could have ended incredibly badly and I
would have been fourth I would settle
that with Lewis because we could we
could get him here we could moderate
some discussion last night in here and I
are gonna hold you by the face and hugs
me and we're gonna figure out the list
but he's gonna tell me that I would have
gone ahead of him simply because of that
dumb video show but he would say dumb
video show in order to to do it because
that was the probably 1988-89 you know
it's one of that one of the nicest
moments I've had on this when I had
Richard Lewis on any left and you know
he's kind of a germaphobe is Larry all
the rage and you know he doesn't shake
hands he does this because he said
goodbye to me I walked him out and when
I opened up the door he just he said
seems like you're great and he touched
me on the cheek and I was like I like
melted I was he does this Rabbinical
thing is that what that it was an erotic
Rabbinical thing that I think he learned
from his shrink probably the other story
which is a very simple one very very
short story I was in San Francisco
performing stand-up I learned that be
careful what you do messing with a
heckler a guy who was about eight feet
tall got up on stage and got me in a
headlock holy [ __ ] and wouldn't let go
of me and had me and was hurting my neck
badly no security nobody there though it
is and I took the
microphone and I shoved it up his ass
and he got so paranoid that I had done
that that he ran away I don't know why
all I know is I don't know if he had a
homophobic frightened moment or it
thought maybe that I was gonna go
further in or maybe that he would have
farted and I would have picked it up on
the mic but in any case that is scary
when you are out there with the people
now let young girls will just flash me
their boobs and go Danny Tanner you know
like that but I've had a few things like
that happen where people have had
security who's had to throw people out
you get all kinds of stuff like that
that won't happen to you an Irvine at
the improv I hope not you've got a hell
of a stand-up career happening because
you have something so you say content
and then you have jokes you're gonna
have you're gonna talk philosophically
like you do on here about life yeah and
then you button it with something
humorous or you feather it throughout
with jokes yeah I mean we talked about
it a little bit but I'm you know there's
two ways sort of that you could do this
so there's the Seinfeld way which is
like that perfect tactician laid out
every pause every inflection point I can
never do it that way I don't think
that's exactly how you do it either no
but then there's sort of the Garry
Shandling way which was you know there's
that great moment in the documentary
comedian where he Jerry shows him his
papers and it looks you know Hitler
wrote it cause it's like so perfect
and then you have Gary Shelley who pulls
out this crumpled piece of paper some
believe that's much closer to what I am
I have some ideas and I did I was on a
beach last week in Florida and I wrote
out the hour and some of it is stuff
that I've done through the years that
I've just updated but it's all based in
what I'm doing here and I'm trying to
just be true I'm just trying to be
trivalent I'm gonna be great yeah and
then you're then you're hooked I know
then you're then you then welcome to the
next thirty years and it'll infiltrate
it will infiltrate this and might not
only be stand-up and you it's an
interesting thing to do to be able to go
hey I'm gonna do Vegas three times this
year and and you know people come to see
me and it's kind of fun and can I get on
the jet with you and Mar you know what
if I if I rock it for the next year
that'll do I go you
the picture I saw the picture yeah you
don't want to be on that you can take it
you don't to be in that one that was
that was a fun trip that was a fun yeah
you guys do that every year you amar
I've never done it without four he
always says he usually has any better do
it who comes in and we didn't maybe had
him on tape and we had Reggie Brown who
did his Obama impression that he's done
on real time before and then he always
has different people he gets different
comedians to come out and do it with him
and he asked me to do it because he
wanted to have some fun and we've always
liked each other I mean we known each
other since 4:23 we all started to go I
took Jerry Seinfeld to Disneyland and
Garry Shandling
and George Wallace and it was the
opening of Thunder Mountain Railroad and
I'll leave you with this because I've
left you with nine other and I don't
want to keep going now - yeah but
there's a goat with dynamite on if
you're been on Thunder Mountain Railroad
I know it but I'm not why does it still
exist anymore oh it's very popular yeah
so there's a goat with dynamite a robot
not you know not much of a robot but
it's a tronic
exactly with a dynamite and you hear it
and all I did for 23 years old and
Jerry's a few months older than me I
think
I went Jerry oh my god a goat with
dynamite and Jerry with Jerry always did
was just lay out the obvious oh my gosh
I glass was a stain you know and that's
not a joke or I'm not him because he's
we growing as there's nothing a clean
glass but but he to this day I could say
oh my god ago a dynamite and he will
laugh because it's when you you know
somebody and you just get them you know
and I saw a bunch of comics last night I
saw Paul Reiser and it was Billy
Crystal's birthday and it's just nice
seeing all these people that I yeah
literally it's so magical that time
right like you came up in a time that to
me and for anyone that appreciates
comedy it's like holy [ __ ] all of these
guys and then you realize there weren't
that many you go like oh there were
thousands of convenience no there
weren't there were hundreds and a lot of
them are gone and then
you know I'm at that two-thirds point
I'd like to think my middle chapter that
means I have to live to 122 with all the
medications these days I think it's
possible motorized unicycle up my butt
with no seat that seems excessive but
whatever whatever works for you we lost
Stephen Hawking just wanted to end on
that yeah
wait you mentioned George Wallace George
George Wald his HBO special which I
think maybe he only had one which is a
real disservice although he's had many
other specialists to me might be the
funniest half-hour there is something
about him and he is was always a friend
of mine always a friend of Jerry's yeah
he's just a funny funny guy and he would
mess with me one time he was opening for
Tom Jones a lot on the road and I lived
in Hollywood on Camino Palmero and he
went out of town but I forgot that he
went out of town and we were buddies and
and and he said he called me up he said
Saget make me chicken I said okay I had
no life you know I was waiting for the
Comedy Store that night you know I was
20 for me okay I'll make you chicken
what do you want just Southern Fried and
in an oven okay sure rate me make this
make me chicken I'll be over in a couple
hours so I make him chicken make a whole
bunch of chicken so pathetic and then he
doesn't come over and now I'm getting
worried William Holden had just died and
so I'm like scared that George died in
his akanda shows you I have grown yeah
as a human I called his landlord and I
got ahold of a building and he said
George's and Tahoe he's nobody behind
John so I called the hotel and I said
George what what did you do is you
[ __ ] idiot I told you I was opening
for Tom Jones why'd you make me chicken
I said I'm freezing it you're gonna eat
it damn it
so that's the end of that story the
George Wallace never eat your chicken
no I ate it was pretty good on that note
Saget I haven't made chicken since until
I came to your house and I saw your
taste all the way you were eyeballing
the one of them
laughs you can have an egg you can't
have the chicken okay can I have an egg
yeah you can leave this house with an
egg I wonder I'm gonna give you a
farm-fresh egg you're not happy - are
you cooking you're not happy that'll
make my sister Bob Saget Danny Tanner
he's walking out of my house with a
farm-fresh egg but but but can I eat it
yeah this debate know what I will cook
it you know what David the chef around
here do you want to literally the best
sunny-side up egg you yeah all right we
are ending this show this really has
been a pleasure like it's so nice when
you meet somebody who you know Sam who
you know but you don't know and then you
realize that you know them something
like that that's the point
I think of what we're supposed to do is
people and we get to do this and we
would do this a dinner this is almost
like does except we just we would move
more yeah I didn't move very much I was
like Captain Pike a little bit yeah all
right I suspect we'll do this over
dinner again and yeah we'll do it here
again and and ah this is I think you got
enough to bear this for three years this
is this is the longest show this is
actually my retirement showdown how long
was this we about six hours that's
fantastic
beyond we went into mountain time for
more on that man Bob Saget check out his
special zero-to-sixty on Amazon and
we've got the link right down below
[Music]
you